okay you can participate in really good
substantive political discussions with
other viewers on our reddit discussion
forum and the reddit discussion forum
the easy way to access it is by going to
david pakman.com slash our EDD i.t we
are now well beyond 4,000 of our viewers
and listeners on the reddit discussion
forum we have moderators on the reddit
discussion forum so if you're concerned
that there is just going to be endless
annoying trolling you don't have to
worry because we have really really good
moderators there it's free and some
really good conversations are going on I
was browsing the reddit this morning and
found some really good conversations
that are going on that I want to mention
to you one of them is a really
interesting discussion of last week's
story about journalism licenses
journalism licenses was this rhetorical
bill that was proposed by Congressman
Jim Lucas and it was sort of meant to
make a point about gun licensing the
idea being hey we have a Second
Amendment which gives us a right to own
firearms and if you're going to licensed
firearms owners then what about
licensing people who are operating under
the First Amendment freedom of the press
license journalists and we pointed out
when we did the story that there is
absolutely no equivalence between the
Second Amendment and the First Amendment
you see the First Amendment say Congress
shall make no law whereas the Second
Amendment just says people are allowed
to own guns that doesn't mean any
firearm it doesn't mean shoulder mounted
RPGs and it doesn't mean you can't have
licensing in any case the discussion on
the reddit discussion forum is about
whether it would be a good idea to
license journalists would we not have
better quality journalism if we had
licenses for journalists and of course
it's hugely problematic when it comes to
this thing called the Constitution so
good discussion at david pakman.com
slash read it another interesting
article posted to the david pakman show
reddit is an article about Ted Cruz
warning of a Watergate style blowout in
2018 I I don't know how many time
and in how many different ways I can say
this no matter what it seems like is
going to happen in 2018 if you think
Trump will be impeached before then if
you think Republicans are gonna lose
control of the house if you think
Republicans are going to lose control of
the Senate in 2018 if you believe as
we're going to talk about later that
Doug Jones is going to defeat Roy Moore
in Alabama in that special election do
not become complacent because I've run
the numbers even with a 34 percent
approval rating Donald Trump could be
reelected in 2020 and the biggest
mistake that progressives could make in
the midterms is just assuming because of
how absurd the Trump administration is
that Democrats are just going to laugh
all the way to inauguration or all the
way to the bank as it often is with our
national elected officials and and that
you could not make a bigger mistake than
that and we saw that partially with
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton in
November of 2016 so get involved no
matter what Ted Cruz is warning us about
get involved in the midterm election
also on the reddit discussion forum the
NFL so far has decided not to create a
rule that would make it official policy
that NFL football players have to stand
during the national anthem and of course
this relates to the major protest that
Donald Trump has also become involved in
surrounding kneeling during the national
anthem before NFL games and there's a
discussion about whether the NFL has
done the right thing or not done the
right thing
in terms of the policy around standing
kneeling sitting or doing whatever else
you want during the national anthem and
it's an interesting discussion I invite
you to participate in and lastly this is
sort of it's a funny story because it
sounds like it would be an onion
headline but it's not there's a Newsweek
article about a man who was rescued from
the Taliban who could not believe that
Donald Trump had become President of the
United States it's a really interesting
read and and I was thinking if you had
been disconnected from world and
American politics for a couple of years
because you were being held captive and
had no access to media I'd probably
question whether Donald
Trump was really the President of the
United States and this goes to the
normalization that takes place over time
over the period that Donald Trump has
been in the public eye we've seen the
normalization of so much crazy that many
of the stories that should be scandals
that we hear about day to day right now
they sort of fall into the background
and this is a double-edged sword if
everything is a scandal nothing is a
scandal and that's why we need to be in
the media responsible with which stories
we're going to make the truly big deal
out of but at the same time there is so
much going on every day that barely
makes a blip because there are so many
other stories that are hard to believe
so anyway I sympathize with this man in
disbelief about Donald Trump being
President of the United States after not
having access to media for a couple of
years and of course the top line is it's
great that he was rescued from being
held hostage by the Taliban